Welcome to this special episode of
What's Up, Prof? Hello, Walter. Hi,
Martin. How are you doing? I'm doing
okay. Oh, well, I'm sure you have to do
okay with you sitting in a setting like
this. Yes, this time it's not a picture.
No. It's reality. The real thing. Yes.
And we have some interesting feedback to
give and we've got some interesting
discussion to do.
So, let's open with a word of prayer and
thank God for doing this.
Heavenly Father, we thank you that we
can be here in this wonderful setting.
We thank you
for the opportunities and all the
blessings that you bestow upon us. We
ask that you
bless this discussion, enlighten our
minds with the Holy Spirit in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen.
Well, Martin,
we've traveled some 3,300
km thus far. Yeah. And what is the
reason for all this traveling?
We were invited to participate in a camp
meeting.
And so, we found a gap
Yeah. and decided to go. So, we went to
the Namibian camp meeting.
Yeah, we asked God to open the doors if
you want it to happen and so it
happened. It was quite stressful because
you know, we had to
uh record a few things in advance in
order to do that and time was limited
and
all the things that pertain to to such
an event. It's it's a long way to drive.
And we decided not to fly because even
if you fly, you have to drive a long way
and you have to rent cars. So, we took
our own cars.
And we traveled from the east of South
Africa
down to
Gauteng where Pretoria and Johannesburg
are.
And then we took the road up through
Botswana. Yes, the Trans-Kalahari
Highway. Yes, and I was so pleasantly
surprised because
the traffic was so much less and the
road was in a fairly good condition.
And I'm not used to that in South Africa
anymore. Our roads are in a horrendous
condition.
True. And the scenery was quite
interesting as well.
Yes, so we traveled through Botswana,
then entered uh
Namibia on the west border
and then traveled up to Gobabis
where the camp meeting was held on a
farm. Yes.
And I think the listeners will be
interested to know that this camp
meeting was in a way very special.
I always love it when a camp meeting
takes place and there are more
non-Adventists than Adventists present.
Yeah, it's more like an outreach. It's
like an outreach and that was the
original intent of a camp meeting in any
case.
Yes.
And with all the turmoils in the world
and all the turmoils amongst nations,
it's interesting to see
that people are concerned about the
times we are living in. Mhm.
And it was a very
it was a very good camp meeting because
we really felt that God was moving upon
hearts.
And we actually had five baptisms
immediately after the camp meeting.
Now, some of these, of course, had been
prepared before.
Others had studied but not made a
decision
and joined in the last minute to be
baptized.
And there are many, many more that are
in the valley of decision. Yeah.
And
we spoke about so many things, Martin.
It was It was interesting.
So, perhaps we can show the viewers a
little bit of the camp meeting. Yeah. It
wasn't a huge camp meeting with
thousands of people.
No.
But if you consider the place and
Namibia and uh
where it was and it wasn't Afrikaans
camp meeting.
So, that meant that uh you know, the
people that came were largely from that
group.
And
this made it all very interesting and
the ideologies
and the different perspectives and the
different religious systems, Calvinism
and and Pentecostalism and all of these
issues and we could we could address all
of these things in private
conversations.
True. It's it was very intimate. Yes. It
was actually, I think, how the Lord
intended it to be. Not sitting there and
getting lost in the great crowd. Yes.
Having this intimate
conversations and meeting with each
other.
Yes, and people could
have one-on-one conversations with us.
And some people are so deeply troubled
and so concerned and
and have such concepts of of God and the
Bible
that you first have to unravel all of
those things and and create hope again.
People are are without hope and they
they are so doom and gloom orientated.
True. It's it's so beautiful when they
can realize that we serve a God of love.
And uh
so, let's show some footage. Yeah, we
can just show a few of the things that
happened.
what happened there at the baptism just
as an introduction.
And then we'll talk about hope and all
that pertains to it. Yes, you can
elaborate a little bit on what you spoke
about at the camp meeting.
Yes, let's do that.
Well, after the camp meeting, we had to
we are on our way traveling back to
South Africa, but
while traveling, there's all these
beautiful scenery.
Can you just explain a little bit more
about where we are?
Yes.
All right, Martin. So, from the camp
meeting,
we decided to take a slightly different
route home.
So, we're going up through the Caprivi
Strip
and then down through Botswana.
And then we have to go back to South
Africa.
And we have the sounds of these birds
talking to us in the background.
Now, that sound that we hear in the
background, that
that is in Afrikaans a kwêvoël. Yeah.
Now, it's called a kwêvoël because it
goes
It's actually a grey loerie
and it's part of the bushveld.
Yeah, and that it's also one of the
birds that's a warning signal.
When there's trouble coming and it's
sitting in a tree, it goes kwê. And then
animals know, okay, there's something
Yes, so hunters don't really like them
because
he warns all the animals in advance, so
I like him.
Yes, it must be as difficult as possible
to
go and slaughter one of God's creatures.
And we're sitting here and the river
behind us is one of the great rivers in
Africa. It's the Okavango that separates
Namibia
from Angola.
And it's got hippos in it and it's got
crocodiles in it and all kinds of
things. So, when you want to go and take
some water from the water's edge, you
better have a good look to see
whether that floating log is really a
floating log or not. Yeah. Yes. And it's
also when it travels into Botswana, it
feeds the Okavango Delta. Yes, and we're
going to go back through that route. So,
it's a very very fascinating area and
it's full of wildlife.
So, it's a very beautiful setting. So,
we're sitting in a campground
and
I'm sleeping in a tent and
Martin is king of the jungle here. He's
sleeping in his roof tent.
And uh
our cars are loaded to max with camera
equipment and
so it's a what shall we call it? A
working drive.
Yeah, yeah, well, it's a
adventure. This is adventure Prof 2.0.
Okay. But we want to talk about some
serious issues while we are here. What
did we speak about at the camp meeting?
So Martin, in a camp meeting, it's
always
important to me to give people hope on
the one hand.
And
on the other hand, tell them where we
are in the stream of time. Yes.
And how necessary it is that we prepare
for what is coming.
So one of the themes we spoke about was
Revelation chapter 5.
And we titled it Worthy Is the Lamb.
And it's actually it's actually a very
important study.
And it has many deep concepts.
So I thought perhaps we could do a
little talk on it. Yeah. Do a WhatsApp
prof on it.
And talk about the aspect of Worthy Is
the Lamb, but then also introduce the
aspects of
where we are in the stream of time.
And the judgments.
Mhm. Now the theme of the camp meeting
was harvest time. Yeah.
It's harvest time, and the camp meeting
song
the theme song was also about the
harvest.
So we are living in the harvest time.
That's right. We need to look at some of
these aspects. So we've titled this
Worthy Is the Lamb. Mhm.
And with this backdrop, I think we can
dive right into it. Please. Yeah, you
see, the thing is
that whole atmosphere of the camp
meeting
show the the object that we had to show
or wanted to show
is that this lamb
died for everyone. Yes, he died for
where the hope lies.
Yes. So this whole thing, and that's
what the harvest is about, is about
hope. Yes, correct. And particularly
since many in in the African context
come from a Calvinistic background. Mhm.
They have this notion of
predestination.
Yes.
That you are predestined
to be saved or to be lost. Mhm.
And this is a rather sad theology.
And
it is a theology that pervades many,
many mindsets.
The selection. God selects.
And God decides beforehand who is going
to be saved and who is going to be lost,
totally negating
freedom of choice in the issue. And then
you don't have it like you said, don't
have a choice. So if God chose you,
you're the a lucky one. Yes. Now my
question is always, what's the point of
evangelism?
And we've given we've given many talks
about this issue before, so I don't want
to talk about selection and
predestination
etc.
But it's a very sad theology because it
paints God in a very
unfavorable light. Yes. It doesn't give
you a choice.
And you are you are chosen for damnation
or you are chosen for
salvation.
On what basis? Yeah. And it's a very
arbitrary basis.
And often, you know, in an area where
there is a lot of racial conflict That's
it. then the criteria that they use are
of a racial nature.
But Christ died for everyone. Mhm.
And he sends us to bring the gospel,
which is good news to the entire world.
Mhm. Every tribe and tongue and nation.
Yes. Now, how can it be good news if
you're going to spread a gospel that
only some are selected and the others
are damned, and you have no part in any
of it?
That's it. And how do you exactly know
that you are chosen? According to your
bloodline? According to your race? Yes.
So it comes very
not a good gospel. Yes. And it's not
it's not a new thing that people think
like this. I mean, the Jews.
They thought they were the chosen race.
Yeah. They were
predestined to salvation. And all the
others were lost.
So rather than being heralds of a of a
great plan of salvation
they ensconced themselves in their
nation.
And condemned everyone that was not part
of it. That's it. So they were the ones
that were saved, and everybody was lost.
And if you have that mindset
then you don't have an evangelism
mindset.
No, cuz what's What's the point?
It's pointless, right?
yourself on a pedestal, and the rest
that you perceive not to be saved
Yes.
so be it. Now if you read the Old
Testament, there are so many places in
the Old Testament
where people from the other nations were
involved. Mhm. If you take Ruth, for
example.
And you take Naaman, for example.
Or you take the Queen of Sheba, for
example. There are so many so many
stories in the Bible
where the gospel was taken and taken to
the world and affected everyone.
I mean, when Jesus
Hi. You're welcome. You're part of the
set.
Panda.
Uh
And Jesus went and taught the
Samaritans.
And the disciples were most displeased.
What was he doing?
Why is he wasting time?
Why is he wasting his time and effort on
people that are lost anyway?
What are you doing here, my dear? Off
you go.
And then And Martin, it's surprising to
me that those with a Calvinistic mindset
were some of the great missionaries in
the world.
Yeah. They went to different parts of
the world to preach the gospel to every
tribe and nation and and people
and believed that only some were going
to be selected and others not, and often
on the basis as we said of race. So
let's not go into that, but No, just
another example is Spurgeon. Yes. One of
the greatest preachers. Yes. And He had
a Calvinistic mindset.
Yeah.
So be that as it may, we're going to
talk about Revelation chapter 5. And the
theme is Worthy Is the Lamb.
And this lamb that was slain
is quite
clearly depicted in Revelation chapter 5
as the lamb that died for everybody
on this
earth.
Yeah.
Here's a quote from Testimonies for the
Church, volume 9.
And it says, "The fifth chapter of
Revelation needs to be closely studied.
It is of great importance to those who
shall act a part in the work of God for
these last days.
There are some who are deceived. They do
not realize what is coming on the earth.
Those who have permitted their minds to
become beclouded in regard to what
constitutes sin
are fearfully deceived. Unless they make
a decided change they will be found
wanting when God pronounces judgment
upon the children of men.
They have transgressed the law and
broken the everlasting covenant, and
they will receive according to their
works."
So here is a message of warning Mhm.
and a message of hope at the same time.
True. And also a measure of judgment.
Judgment is involved, and the law is
involved because the law is the standard
of judgment, right?
That's it. So we have to look into this
issue and see what is this all about?
Mhm.
And
why is it important that we discuss
these things in the times that we are
living in?
So let's go to Revelation chapter 5.
Revelation chapter 5.
And I saw in the right hand of him that
sat on the throne a book
written within and on the backside,
sealed with seven seals.
Now Martin
this kind of scroll
Mhm. written on both sides, rolled up,
sealed with seven seals
is something that was quite common in
ancient times.
And in in the Roman society
a will
a testament was sealed with seven seals
sometimes.
Uh the number seven, as we have
discussed before, means fullness.
Mhm.
And it is
full to the brim. That was the root of
the Hebrew word for seven. Now this is,
of course, the New Testament, so it's
written in Greek.
But that's basically the meaning of the
word seven.
So here was this scroll, sealed with
seven seals.
And I saw a strong angel proclaiming
with a loud voice, "Who is worthy to
open the book and to loose the seals
thereof?"
And no man in heaven, nor in earth,
neither under the earth, was able to
open the book, neither to look there on.
Mhm. So, this is a very
very
serious issue.
It's obviously important that this book
should be opened. Now, if we assume that
it is a testament,
Yes. that it is a will,
Mhm.
a will can only go into effect once
someone has died.
True. Cuz you might be the beneficiary
of your father's will,
but you receive nothing
until there is a death, right?
Yeah.
And this is this is the testament. A
will and a testament.
And obviously then there's an
inheritance. So, there's an inheritance
and an inheritor.
But somebody has to die in order for
this to become reality.
Now, who is going to open the scroll?
And it is of paramount important that
the scroll be opened, otherwise the
inheritance is lost.
That's it.
Because if the will is not read, there
can be no execution of that will.
So, this is so important that somebody
should be found worthy to open the
scroll. Now, obviously it can't be just
anybody.
Because it says plainly that no man in
heaven. So, nobody
that is in heaven, no created being in
heaven,
no angel, no created being from other
realms, nobody in heaven was worthy.
Nobody on earth was worthy either. So,
no human being can open the scroll,
neither under the earth. So, nobody who
had died Mhm. would be able to open that
scroll either.
Cuz they're basically dead.
So, what do we need? We need a very
special circumstance.
So, nobody was able to open the book,
neither to look there on. Mhm. In other
words, you can't even How can you see
what's inside of it if you don't open it
up to look there on?
And I wept because no man was found
worthy to open and to read the book,
neither to look there on. Now, why did
he weep? Because obviously if the scroll
is not opened, there's no inheritance.
Means it's lost.
It's lost. That means everything is
lost.
And who's involved? Heaven is involved.
Because they were looking in heaven to
see if there was anybody that was
worthy. To open it, yes. And there was
nobody.
Because how can they open it? Because
nobody
had died, or somebody needs to have died
in order to open the scroll. And then
also nobody had the authority. And
nobody had the authority. And what is
this testament all about?
So, this is fascinating.
And one of the elders says unto me,
"Weep not." Now, Martin, this is a
heavenly scene. Mhm. We're talking about
heavenly things. What's happening in
heaven?
So, there's a discussion about the
inheritance, and there's a discussion
about the book.
And this is a heavenly discussion. It's
taking place in heaven.
Heaven.
And one of the elders said unto me,
"Weep not because the lion of the tribe
of Judah, the root of David, has
prevailed upon the book
and to loose the seven seals thereof."
Now, the lion of the tribe of Judah, we
know who that is. That is Christ. Now,
this is a description of him in his
regal form, in his military capacity.
And is it also kingly? Yes, he's the
lion of the tribe of Judah. Lion was a
symbol of the tribe of Judah as well.
And as a lion, he is a conqueror. He is
a king. He is a a a general that leads
the hosts of heaven.
So, this depicts power and authority and
might and glory and all of these issues.
But it's interesting that it's not in
that capacity that he is able to open
the scroll.
True, now. That is He can't open the
scroll in that capacity. So, all the
power in the world, all the glory on the
world, all the might in the world, all
the
the brilliance in military matters will
not enable him to open the scroll as the
lion of the tribe of Judah, but that's
who he is.
Yes. That's one of his attributes.
That's one of his attributes. That's an
attribute.
And I beheld, and lo, in the midst of
the throne and of the four beasts, and
in the midst of the elders,
stood a lamb
as it had been slain. Mhm.
There's the key.
Yes. Having seven horns, seven eyes,
which are the seven spirits of God sent
forth into all the earth.
So, here associated with the lamb,
obviously is the one that's going to
open the scroll.
We also have associated with him his
other title, the lion of the tribe of
Judah, which we've discussed. But it is
in his capacity as the lamb that had
been slain, that has seven horns.
Now, a horns is a king or ruler.
have another horn in Revelation, a
little horn that grows up mightily.
So, here is one, seven horns, but we're
also covering a time scale. Yes.
A historic time scale.
And we're we're talking about the time
scale
since the scroll was opened.
So, in order for the scroll to be
opened, somebody had to die.
Now, here we have someone that died. The
lamb. A lamb Mhm. that was slain.
And this means that he is able to open
the scroll.
But in order to open the scroll, if he
is the lamb that was slain,
he has to be dead Mhm. for this to come
into effect.
Yes. But if he is also the inheritor,
Yes, he's the
one that opens it, he has to be alive.
He has to be a inheritor. So, it says a
lamb as it had been slain. Mhm. So, he's
alive.
So, it's in the capacity of the lamb
that was slain
that he is able to open the scroll and
be the inheritor at the same time.
This is this is the the intricacy of the
plan of salvation. It's it's absolutely
brilliant.
And we have number of periods prior to
chapter 5, you have, for example,
chapter 3 in the book of Revelation,
where you go through the seven churches.
Mhm.
And that's a time period
of the history of the Christian church.
Mhm.
And what would happen to it. It actually
falls
into
like we mentioned in last days. Yes. The
Christian era. Yeah.
That whole period and then different
eras and areas in that period
constitutes that this churches and also
these seals.
And if you read about the seven
churches, you have the the the idea of
conflict.
Because it starts off
with the first church
that is uh
full of fire and has, you know, the
gospel in its purity. And then there is
a decline, and then you have the middle
church, which is a church in darkness.
Then you have light
emanating again from that darkness, and
then you have the last church, which is
in a Laodicean state. Yeah.
So, you have this flow through history.
So, the number seven, the seven time
periods, he is the one in control of all
of those time periods.
Mhm.
And he has seven eyes. So, he's God, and
he sees everything.
Mhm.
And he's going to give us the
information as to what this battle is
all about,
and the decisions that we have to make
with regard
to this battle,
and the choice we have to make.
Yeah. What side are we going to take?
Mhm.
So, here is a heavenly discussion of
this this unsealing of the scroll.
And then it says, "Which are the seven
spirits of God sent forth
into all the earth."
So, Martin, who's this is who's this
message for that has to be given to the
entire world?
Once again, every tribe and tongue and
nation. All right. So, the message
basically deals with an inheritance.
Mhm.
And you can either be part of that
inheritance, or you could choose not to
be part of that inheritance, right?
It's actually
a little bit different than a
earthly testament.
Yes. Because here you can choose if you
want to inherit this or not. Correct.
Now, Martin, when you inherit,
do you necessarily only inherit the good
and the goods, or do you sometimes
inherit a package which has negatives in
it as well?
Unfortunately, yes. Everything. All
right. So, if your father was heavily
indebted,
there will not be much left of that
inheritance, right?
True.
And here we have a situation where we
have actually a cosmic conflict.
And an inheritance that was lost.
And an inheritance that had to be
regained.
But in order to gain the inheritance,
somebody has to die.
So, this is a This is a fascinating
story, and we need to unravel this
chapter 5.
Yes. And understand what this lamb is
all about.
That is worthy.
Now, here's a quote from Acts of the
Apostles, and it reads, "The savior is
presented before John under the symbol
of the lion of the tribe of Judah,
and of a lamb as it had been slain."
Revelations 5:5 and 6. These symbols
represent the union of omnipotent power
and self-sacrificing love.
The lion of the tribe of Judah, so
terrible to the rejecters of his grace,
will be the lamb of God to the obedient
and faithful.
That's very well put, huh?
beautifully. Now you understand how
these two get together. Yes.
The pillar of fire that speaks of terror
and wrath to the transgressor of God's
law
is a token of light and mercy and
deliverance to those who have kept the
commandments.
God is always a majority.
When the sound of the last trump will
penetrate the prison house of the dead,
and the righteous shall come forth with
triumph,
exclaiming, "O death, where is thy
sting? O grave, where is thy victory?"
Standing then with God, with Christ,
with the angels, and with the loyal and
true of all ages, the children of God
will be far in the majority.
Christ's true disciples follow him
through sore conflicts, enduring
self-denial,
and experiencing bitter disappointment.
But this teaches them the guilt and woe
of sin.
And they are led to look upon it with
abhorrence. Partakers of Christ's
suffering,
they are destined to be partakers of his
glory.
Isn't that a beautiful quote?
Yes, it's
It puts the whole plan of salvation in
perspective. All right. So, when he
opens that scroll,
and we read about the great inheritance,
we also read about the price
Yes. that was paid in order to gain the
inheritance.
That's it.
We also read about the conflict involved
in regaining the inheritance.
Because why did he weep?
Because everything was lost. If that
scroll wasn't opened, everything was
lost.
So, what the scroll contains is
information on the great cosmic
conflict,
and how it is resolved,
and the choices that you have to make
between
either confronting the lion of the tribe
of Judah,
or coming before the lamb as it was
slain. That's a choice, right?
And then receiving the glory, the
inheritance.
Yes.
Here's a quote from Testimonies to
Ministers and Gospel Workers, "The
uplifted savior is to appear in his
efficacious work as the lamb slain,
sitting upon the throne to dispense the
priceless covenant blessings,
the benefits he died to purchase for
every soul who should believe on him."
John could not express that love in
words. It was too deep, too broad.
He calls upon the human family to behold
it.
Christ is pleading for the church in the
heavenly courts above, pleading for
those for whom he had paid the
redemption price of his own lifeblood.
Centuries, ages can never diminish the
efficacy of that atoning sacrifice.
The message of the gospel of his grace
was to be given to the church in clear
and distinct lines,
that the world should no longer say that
Seventh-day Adventists talk the law, the
law, but do not teach or believe Christ.
Well, that's a rap across the knuckles.
You see,
because
most people still do that. Yes, many do.
They believe that if they are in harmony
with the law,
that somehow they've inherited
righteousness. They inherit no
righteousness.
Because an unrighteous soul cannot pick
himself up from his death stupor
and give himself life. Only Christ can,
right?
So, the law is essential because that's
the one that condemned us, but who
redeems us from the curse of the law?
Only Christ. Only Christ redeems us from
the curse of the law.
So, the message of the gospel is really
about righteousness by faith.
Well, like you previously also
explained, it's actually the crux.
And the atonement is an essential part.
So, can we assume, Martin,
that the enemy will attack righteousness
by faith? It'll be one of his main
points to go for. And will he attack the
atonement? Absolutely. Oh, yeah. I I
think he hates the atonement.
He hates the atonement. All right.
So, if he if he's going to replace it
with a message of righteousness by
works,
then he will be negating
the message of the lamb that was slain.
True. But he actually put in another one
as well. Okay. How many people have been
slain in this world?
Oh, millions, billions. Millions, but
none of them could atone. No. None of
them. There was no atonement in any of
those deaths. So,
those deaths had no part in your or my
salvation. No. Only one death
and one resurrection
had a part to play in our salvation.
Well, but I like I said in just earlier,
he
comes in with righteousness by works.
But then he also has another one
covering that you are all one saved,
always saved. That's That's a new
theology, one saved, always saved. So,
you've got these two extremes. So, it's
not rocket science to ask yourself,
"Who's the enemy of the atonement, and
who's the enemy of righteousness by
faith?"
You only have to look at the the papal
decrees to know who the enemy is.
Those who claim righteousness by faith
are anathema according to the Council of
Trent.
They are cursed forever.
And
we agree with that little bird. There
you go.
And the atonement, I mean, to attack the
atonement is such an affront.
And the Jesuits have the gall
to attack the atonement and say that
Christ never died for you. It was only
an example.
And they put their saints
on the same level or on a higher level
even than Christ.
And one of the saints that they love to
elevate
and compare in terms of the atonement is
the saint St. Francis.
Yeah.
And we have a Jesuit pope who calls
himself by that name,
who denies the atonement and denies
righteousness by faith. They are enemies
of God. Like you just mentioned, that's
the whole thing. If you are on that
side,
the enemy
he don't wants to get rid of the
atonement. So, actually then you are of
your father the devil. Right. So, the
law is very important because the law
tells us what is right and what is
wrong.
The law does not save us. No.
So, people should understand that when
you understand the issue of law and
grace, you will put them in the right
perspective.
And we're going to talk a little bit
about
the glory of the lamb
and why the lamb is worthy.
So, now in Revelation 5:7,
the lamb goes and takes the book out of
the right hand of him that sat upon the
throne.
Now, that's God the Father. God the
Father is sitting there,
and the lamb is worthy to take the
scroll.
And when he had taken the book, the four
beasts
and the four and 20 elders fell down
before the lamb, having every one of
them harps and the golden vials full of
odors, which are the prayers of the
saints.
Now, this is a very beautiful image,
Martin.
So, he takes the scroll,
and the heavenly beings, the cherubs
that surround the throne, the four of
them,
and the elders,
in other words, the representatives of
the created worlds,
fall down, this is a heavenly scene,
and basically worship the lamb, right?
Mhm.
And they have something in their hand,
namely golden vials full of odors, which
are the prayers of the saints.
So, obviously, there's a conflict going
down going on down here on this earth.
And the prayers of the saints
ascend to God.
I love these accompanying sounds.
They ascend to God,
and they are part and parcel of what is
happening there in heaven.
So, heaven is not disconnected
No. from earth. No.
It is connected via the prayers.
It also comes back to, you know, the
theology that God created, but he did He
distances himself, yes. Yeah, like
deists believe.
This actually shows you, no.
God is involved, intimately involved.
the whole heaven is involved. Now, where
do those where do those prayers go? They
go right up to the throne, right?
Mhm.
And surely those prayers,
which are prayers of
concern,
your personal life, everything involved
with this battle between good and evil
and the choices, and all the requests
that go up to heaven, they're not lost.
No. They're kept in not ordinary vials,
golden vials.
So, this is this is total involvement
of every praying
person down here on this earth. And
often
it is the prayers of even one
that makes it possible for God to act
even upon amongst those that hate him.
Yeah. And very often saves their lives.
True.
I mean, Moses, how many times did he
pray on behalf of the whole
congregation? Yes. And you sing that
song, the song of Moses, right? You sang
that at the camp meeting.
Yes, we'll record that.
Together with my wife.
Yeah.
Did you record it? No, not yet. Oh. We
will record it in the future.
start getting a move on, right?
Uh Beautiful words.
Yes.
Now, Sonica put that music together,
and I think she penned the the words as
well, using the Psalms, of course.
But that's another story. So, now you're
on notice, Martin. That's good. That old
song actually tells also a story of
righteousness by faith and the
deliverance. Okay.
So, let's have a look at the Review and
Herald and see what
is written about these golden vials full
of odors, which are the prayers of the
saints.
The work of God is to be carried on to
completion by the cooperation of divine
and human agencies.
Those who are self-sufficient may be
apparently active in the work of God,
but if they are prayerless,
their activity is of no avail.
Cuz that's all that comes up to God,
right?
Could they look into the sensor of the
angel that stands at the golden altar
before the rainbow-circled throne,
they would see that the merit of Jesus
must be mingled with the prayers and
efforts, or they are worthless,
as was the offering of Cain.
Could we see all the activity of human
instrumentality
as it appears before God,
we would see that only the work
accomplished by much prayer,
which is sanctified by the merit of
Christ,
will stand the test of the judgment.
When the grand review shall take place,
then shall you return and discern
between him that serveth God and him
that serveth him not.
So, Martin, if we don't pray,
our efforts are useless.
That's true. You know what
And if our prayers are selfish, Yeah.
they're even more useless. And that like
we'll see
if the prayers is not
mixed with the righteousness of Christ,
it cannot be anything before the throne
room as well.
So, righteousness of of Christ, the
atonement, and the interaction
between the heavenly realm and the
earthly realm
can only be built on prayer. That's it.
And then, if you read
on different portions of the Spirit of
Prophecy,
song
is as much
as prayer
in divine service. Correct. So, Martin,
we must talk about music at some stage.
Definitely.
And they sang a new song. Well, you just
said that.
They sang a new song saying, "Thou art
worthy to take the book and to open the
seals thereof, for thou was slain,
and has redeemed us to God by thy blood
and out of every kindred and tongue and
people and nation." Now, let's just go
back to that camp meeting with all of
these ideologies.
Can it be planned on this? No.
All right?
"Thou has redeemed us to God by thy
blood." Mhm. How dare
they say that we are not redeemed by the
blood of the lamb, like the Jesuits do?
How dare they?
In direct contradiction
to this verse.
And who's who is the price paid for?
Yeah.
Every kindred.
Is there any selection or
any any superiority involved here?
Again, so how dare you say that?
And tongue.
Every language group, everybody, and
people and nation. So, who's salvation
for? Everybody. Everybody. The price was
paid for everybody. And if you do not
understand this, it is an affront to
God.
Yeah. It is actually an accusation. That
is.
And if there were such a thing as
selection, then all those that are
selected against
have the absolute right to confront God
and say that your judgments are not
fair.
Mhm. But this lamb is worthy.
He is worthy,
and has made us unto our God kings and
priests.
Isn't that amazing? So,
from the depth of degradation,
lifted up to the level of rulers
Yes.
and priests.
Now, priests are the ones who are
supposed to represent the Godhood.
And if you represent the Godhood in a
false light,
there's a serious issue, right?
True.
And we shall reign on the earth.
And I beheld and I heard the voice of
many angels round about the throne and
the beasts and the elders, and the
number of them was 10,000 * 10,000 and
thousands and of thousands, that's
millions upon millions. That's a
majority, right?
That's it.
Saying with a loud voice, "Worthy is the
lamb
that was slain."
Now, what is it worthy of? To receive
power Mhm.
and riches
and wisdom and strength and honor and
glory and blessing. That's quite a long
list, Martin. True. Now, in order to
receive the power and the riches, well,
he has the power, he's the the lion of
the tribe of Judah,
but in order to gain the inheritance, he
had to be slain.
Slain.
And in order to gain the inheritance, he
also had to be resurrected.
Cuz otherwise, you can't inherit. No.
All right.
had to be
risen up to be alive again to receive
And all the riches that were lost could
only be regained by becoming a lamb
Yeah. that was slain.
And wisdom and strength and honor and
glory and blessing.
And every creature which is in heaven
and on the earth and under the earth,
that means everybody who's in heaven,
all the angelic host,
all the created worlds,
and everybody on earth and everybody
that has died,
and such as are in the sea,
amongst the nations or even literally
buried at sea,
and all that are in them heard I saying,
"Blessing and honor and glory and power
be unto him that sitteth upon the throne
and unto the lamb forever and ever." Do
we have a father and son
description here?
Yes.
And the four beasts said, "Amen."
And the four and 20 elders fell down and
worshipped him
that liveth forever and ever. Martin,
if all the heavenly beings here
fell down and worshipped him,
must he be God?
Can only be God because that only God
can accept worship.
All right. So, this is a very, very
important that we understand every
single nuance of the book of Revelation.
Mhm. And chapter 5 introduces us
to the whole plethora of what is
happening there.
So, so let's just try and get a little
glimpse of what happened here.
The scroll in the right hand of him that
sat on the throne, Christ, the beloved
of God, came to assert the claims of the
owner of the vineyard.
But the husbandmen treated him with mock
contempt, saying, "We will not have this
man to rule over us."
They hated the high standard of
righteousness which Christ continually
represented.
They saw that his teaching was placing
them where their selfishness would be
uncloaked.
And they determined to kill him.
They hated his example of truthfulness
and piety and the elevated spirituality
revealed in all he did.
Well, you see,
even the followers of Christ has to go
through this now. Yes, absolutely.
"Shall I crucify your king?" Pilate
asked.
And from the priests and rulers came the
answer, "We have no king but Caesar."
Martin,
is the Christian and the evangelical
world on the same road?
That's what I mean. Exactly.
saying, "We have no king but Caesar" and
they make the Pope the head of the
ecumenical movement?
And by obeying his dictates, don't they
worship him?
Cannot do any other.
When Pilate washed his hands saying,
"I'm innocent of the blood of this just
person," the priests joined with the
ignorant mob declaring passionately,
"His blood be on us and on our
children."
Thus, the Jewish leaders made their
choice. Their decision was registered in
the book which John saw in the hand of
him that sat upon the throne. Because in
this in book of inheritance, there is
also a description of the conflict.
Mhm.
And who accepts it and who does not
accept it because
part of the inheritance
is not only the kingdom regained,
but the people redeemed. Yes.
And here we have the issue of choice.
Mhm.
The Jewish leaders made a choice.
That's it. And that's why
they were
not accepted as part of that
inheritance. So, it's very important
that we understand that.
What is the inheritance about and how do
you gain it?
You have to accept
the lamb slain. You have to accept him
as king. Yeah.
They had to bow down. Even the heavenly
beings bowed down. They refused. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
So, when their decision was registered
in the book which John saw in the hand
of him that sat upon the throne, the
book which no man could open.
In all its vindictiveness, this decision
will appear before them in the day when
the book is unsealed by the lion of the
tribe of Judah. So, Martin, this book
contains that history. Mhm.
But
that history is 2,000 years ago. Yes.
Do you want to be part of that history
as well? Yes.
And that choice? I want to because
otherwise I can't be an inheritor. So,
it can't only contain that portion. It
must contain the rest as well, right?
True.
So, we read in manuscript releases
volume 9 that the book with seven seals
contains the history of the world.
There in his open hand lay the book, the
roll of the history of God's
providences, the prophetic history of
the nations and the church.
Herein was contained the divine
utterances, his authority, his
commandments, his laws, the whole
symbolic counsel of the eternal and the
history of the ruling powers of the
nations.
Because it deals with choice.
Mhm. Who chooses what?
In symbolic language was contained in
that roll the influence of every nation,
tongue, and people from the beginning of
the earth's history
to its close.
So, if I could sum it up, Martin, so if
I could write,
only those that have learned the lessons
of humility and obedience can be
translated and glorified.
Humanity seeks glorification without
meeting the requirements. Mhm.
A character transformed to reflect the
character of Christ.
They seek the lion of the tribe of Judah
to release them from their
circumstantial bondage, but not from the
bondage of sin.
Yeah. You know what the Jews did?
Yeah, but most people they they want to
be saved in their sin. I hear so many
times, "God does nothing for me."
Mhm.
Is salvation not something for you?
They do not seek humility of the lamb
and the least of all the lamb slain,
which testifies of self-sacrificing
love.
The message of warning to the world is a
call to repentance and must be heeded
first before we can qualify for
exaltation.
And that is the whole plan. You cannot
jump the gun and do it oh, I'm saved
and I can continue what I've been doing
all along.
Correct. Now, Martin,
only the lamb slain Mhm. was deemed
worthy.
Now,
if we take our minds back
to the very first
death
of an animal that took place on this
earth.
Adam and Eve had sinned
and they'd hidden themselves.
Yes.
And they they saw that they were naked.
They had lost the robe of righteousness
that had covered them before. Yes.
And they hid themselves and they made
for themselves coverings of fig leaves.
Now, humanity loves the covering of fig
leaves
and rejects the covering of the
righteousness of the lamb.
Yes, always want to do it on their own.
They want to do it
on their own terms. And even today in
Freemasonry, you have the apron
and the apron represents the fig leaf.
And it is a bold statement of covering
yourself with your own righteousness.
Now, that righteousness was seamless.
Mhm.
Now,
when God called out to Adam, "Where are
you?"
And Adam said, "I was afraid."
Then God pronounced
a solemn decree.
"I will put enmity
between thee and the woman, Yeah.
between thy seed and her seed.
And he shall crush thy head or it shall
crush thy head.
And he But he Mhm. shall bruise thy
heel."
Mhm.
That is the declaration of war
against the serpent
and the seed of the serpent, those that
adopt the mindset of the serpent.
Yes.
And the seed of the woman. Now, that
seed, according to Paul, is singular and
refers to Christ.
Yeah. And everybody who is in that seed,
who is in Christ,
is part of this promise.
But there will be enmity.
And then
animals had to die. The Bible doesn't
say what kind of animal died. It must
have been a clean animal.
Mhm.
And
who killed it?
Well, if we we look at the sanctuary,
then the sinner had to slay the lamb.
That's it.
So, I assume that Adam had to slay
the first animals.
But then it says that God
Yes.
took the skins
and he made a robe for them and covered
them with the skins.
Mhm.
Now, that animal, let's say there was
also a lamb there.
That animal,
let's say there was a lamb there,
represents the lamb that was slain.
That's the first promise of redemption
through atonement.
Yes.
Now, if that animal was lying there and
it was slain
and the skin had been removed,
then that is actually a death sentence
that God proclaimed upon himself.
That's it. Because he represents the
lamb that was slain. That's it. And that
nakedness
of the animal or the skinless is the
righteousness removed.
order to remove that skin
and place it onto Adam and Eve because
he made skins for Adam and for Eve.
That means that lamb was dead.
Yes, it had to die. It had to die.
That's quite a deep thought, right?
Now in order for that lamb
to regain everything and to unseal the
scroll and to be able to do all of these
things,
then there must have been a
resurrection. Yeah.
But there must have been a death.
Now if you go to to Calvary,
when Christ was lifted up on that cross,
uh where was his robe?
They cast lots for it.
Yes, because they couldn't tear it.
Couldn't tear it.
Because it was seamless. There was no
seam in the robe of righteousness, in
that robe that represented his
righteousness.
But it was removed from him.
And it was handed to
the guards and they cast lots for it. So
how did he hang there on that cross?
Totally naked.
Yeah.
Just like that first animal.
Stripped of its skin.
It was totally
naked.
Exposed.
Just like Adam and Eve. Before they made
robes of their own righteousness, but
that couldn't save them. Those fig
leaves had to be removed.
So any system that is based on salvation
by your works, like Freemasonry or
Catholicism that controls it through its
Jesuit orders,
has to
has to remove that robe of fig leaves
and have it replaced with a robe of
righteousness that comes from Christ.
And let me think Martin about the
the event that took place there.
And you and you realize that God himself
there in type, in demonstration,
says, "This is what I am going to do for
you. I am going to die."
That's the only way that I will be able
to regain the inheritance.
Mhm. It is actually unfathomable.
But I will put enmity between thee and
the woman, between thy seed and her
seed.
And it shall
crush thy head.
Now if you
fast forward a little bit to the time of
David,
where you have David and Goliath,
Yes.
is another typological story.
And the
the Philistine
represents
Satan, right?
And it's interesting if you read a
little bit later, it tells you about his
brothers
that they had six fingers. So the number
six is associated with with him, six
fingers and six toes. So we assume that
Goliath also had six fingers. It doesn't
say so, but we can assume so.
It was part of his family.
The number six is associated with it.
And David went and he took five little
stones.
He selected them. Yes. Now five is the
number of humanity.
Correct. You have five senses, right?
Mhm.
So he selected five stones.
Now that was enough for Goliath,
but it was also enough for his brothers.
Yes.
Who weren't killed by David, but
subsequently by others from the children
of Israel.
And Goliath came forth and he he
accosted and mocked.
And he blasphemed the God of heaven. Who
is this uncircumcised Philistine that he
should, you know,
rail against the God of Israel.
And as he came forward, he said, uh
"What is Am I a dog that you come with
me with with stones and with a stick?"
And he must have, you know, lifted his
hand to get a better look and that was
his death sentence and he was struck
here in the forehead. Mhm. Now what sits
there in the forehead, Martin?
Your cognitive decision-making.
The prefrontal cortex. So that was was
destroyed here in in the skull.
And then David
cut off his head Yeah. with his own
sword.
Now what does the sword represent? What
is the sword of the spirit?
The word of God.
The word of God. So the sword of Goliath
must be his words.
Mhm. Mhm. So his head was cut off with
his own sword, so his own words condemn
him.
Now if he's a type of Satan, wasn't he a
liar from the beginning?
That's it. His own righteousness.
And we spoke about lies in a previous
one.
Yeah.
And one of the lies that he that he
presents is that you don't have a
savior. You don't have a redeemer. There
is no atonement. You have to do this by
yourself.
And then David took the armor.
And the Bible says that he took it to
his own tent. Mhm. And he lived in
Bethlehem, the breadbasket.
Yeah. Yeah, the typologies are so
beautiful.
But the head,
the head,
he didn't take that and put it into his
own tent. He took that to Jerusalem.
Mhm.
Now that was a practice in in ancient
times. Mhm. So he had the head of
Goliath in his hand and he took it to
Jerusalem and he went and stood on top
of a mount.
And basically,
he told them, the Jebusites that
occupied Jerusalem at that time, "that
you're next."
Yeah.
In other words, Jerusalem,
which is a type of all the redeemed,
will be conquered and the and the
Jebusites, almost I said Jesuits, which
is very close to the same thing,
will be expelled.
Yeah.
And there on top of that hill, he stood
with that skull and said, "What happened
to Goliath Mhm. is going to happen to
you."
And that which was lost to the enemies
of God will be regained.
And Martin, is it
possible or maybe even probable that he
buried that skull on top of that mount?
Mhm. Definitely. And that mount would be
Calvary. Yeah.
That well, Golgotha.
But it was part of the Temple Mount at
that stage.
Because later on they quarried the
stones out and it became two separate
hills.
But here, on top of that mount where the
temple would stand, the symbol of
redemption,
he buried that skull.
And later on, when Christ came and he
walked on that road,
he must have trod over the place where
that skull was or maybe even when that
cross was put into the hole,
it could have maybe even literally
crushed that skull.
And there's one example in the museum in
Jerusalem
of a crucifixion.
Now unlike the way we depict it in the
in the pictures of the world, the
crucifixion
didn't actually the the nails didn't
penetrate the foot from the front. It
went through the side of the of the heel
and then it was nailed to the pole
from the sides. That's how There's one
one archaeological find
where it shows how those nails were put
through the heel.
So the skull was crushed
and the heel of Christ was bruised.
So there's beautiful symbolism in that,
Martin. God does not put anything in
arbitrarily.
lost.
And if you look at that symbolism and
and what it costs to redeem us, the
Bible says that we are redeemed by water
and blood, right?
Now
before the crucifixion,
Jesus crossed the Kidron Valley
and he went to the other side where was
the Garden of Gethsemane.
And there the Bible tells us that he was
in such agony
because he felt the separation from his
father
and because the sins of the whole world
were laid upon his shoulders.
And the stress caused water and blood
sweat
and blood mingled to drip from his face
in that garden.
And later on, when we come to Calvary,
we read that the spear pierced his side
and two streams flowed out, water
and blood.
These are the symbols of redemption.
That's it. Yeah.
Now,
the Garden of Gethsemane was on the one
side of the Kidron Valley,
and Calvary was here on the other side.
Now, on that very hill stood also the
temple, where there were many
sacrificial offerings.
And much blood was spoke.
Yeah.
Now, that blood
was transferred to the Kidron Valley.
And they washed it with water. Yes, to
get it out.
it down into these pipes that they had
laid into the Kidron Valley. And all
that blood that flowed from all of those
sacrificial animals,
and all of those lambs, and all of those
bulls, and all of those creatures, that
lamb that blood represented salvation,
and the water represented the cleansing.
And it flowed down into that Kidron
Valley. In the same way, the blood of
Christ and the water, the sweat and the
blood mingled, flowed down.
And when he was on the cross, they'd
given him a crown of thorns.
They'd actually given him a coronation,
because they put a royal robe on him,
they put a a fake uh
scepter
scepter into his hand.
And all that was left on on that cross
was the crown,
which didn't penetrate the skull,
but the blood poured out of the skin and
mingled with the sweat that ran down his
face. So,
the antitypical blood and the water
flowed into the Kidron Valley. Then you
read in the book of Ezekiel
that this water rose in the Kidron
Valley,
and then the trees stood up, and the
water flowed through the desert. And
wherever it flowed through the desolate
areas,
there the great uh
vegetation flourished.
Yeah, so life Life came back, and even
down to the Dead Sea, which is a symbol
of death,
in permanent death, life arose again.
So, the stream of water and blood that
came from the plan of salvation
was to give life even to the desolate
places, and the gospel had to go out
into the entire world.
It's a beautiful typology of the plan of
salvation. Worthy is the lamb that was
slain, Martin. We should never forget
that.
Oh, you cannot and that is the way that
we have to go forward.
And only by that righteousness covering
you. Yes, and there he hung, with no
clothes on him, Martin. Nothing.
Totally naked, so that you and I, and
anybody that believes in him, could be
covered with that robe of righteousness.
No wonder
the heavenly beings fell down before the
throne and said, "Worthy,
worthy is the lamb
that was slain."
And but we still have large parts of
this prophecy to discuss, but I think we
should do that in in the next
session. Definitely. So, we
close off this one, please. Perhaps we
should end off with contemplating
why the lamb that was slain was worthy
to open the scroll,
so that you and I, together with him,
and in him, might have an inheritance.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we want to thank you
for the lamb
that was slain on our behalf.
And because he was slain,
he was worthy to open the scroll,
and to give us
an insight into the great conflict
that took place
from the time that sin entered the
universe
to the final close, which is just around
the corner.
Help us to understand these issues,
that we may internalize them,
and understand the character of God, the
one who died for us,
the one who spilt his blood for us,
and the one who cleansed us with living
water, so that we may never thirst
again.
Thank you for that gift of salvation.
And we ask it in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.